Doing a lot seems so impulsive to me so
little strategic in certain topics in
his business topics he is certainly
very strategic but his
communication is so impulsive that's what
makes him so successful I think
I can't even imagine
him sitting there and  I thought about it: I
want to land a prq here somehow
or do you think that was an
impulse and did he notice, okay, there's
something to come afterwards, it's fun, it gets
even more attention, keep it going
World class works,
strictly
speaking, to push its place somehow
above it  To
get out of his boring image like
Sandman Location, I think he posted it on
Instagram
and then he
downloaded it again, he would finish the element
so badly, so I
even think I would finish Elon Musk
with my minimal technique because I
just trained